I thought before going into today's topic,
I will give you a five minute summary of what happened last time.
So you guys are saying,
look,
uh,
it looks like you got carried away with this thing.
We just want to know what we need to become good doctors.
Okay,
so just tell us.
So he had a doctor or the lawyer.
I've had really strong students in my class who had nothing to do with any of
the sciences,
physics or chemistry,
which of course a great pleasure for me to know.
So if you go far into your life's mission at what should you know from the last
lecture?
Here's the main point.
The law of conservation of energy is a powerful concept that I told you survives
even the quantum revolution.
So it looks like we may have scraped the system,
something called the total energy with the kinetic energy,
which is always one half MV square and potential energy,
which depends on the location of the object.
And it varies from problem to problem depending on whether they're connected
with spraying or gravity and so on.
In one dimension.
We could always get set the potential energy for any force that dependent only
on location.
The trick was to go back to the work,
enter the theater them,
but just applies Newton's laws and say is the change in Kennedy get energy of
the body?
Is the work done by the body and that work we defined to be this?
Then the sum of all of this on the left hand side would be the tended candidate
energy.
On the right hand side.
This will become the integral of f from x one two x two and if f really it's a
function of x amount of also velocity loss of calculus tell you,
you may write this integral as a difference of two numbers.
Then you rearrange the expression to get k one plus you want,
you want to shorthand for you have x one is kid too plus youtube and that means
the energy he wants to begin with energy at the end.
If that is the frictional force,
then in these integral you break it up into two parts.
The part said you'd do a spring and the part due to friction,
the part due to a spring will integrate to give you this,
then you will still have the part due to friction leftover.
In that case,
that is silver look like k one k two plus you two minus k one plus you one
instead of being zero will be the work done by friction.
Um,
we write it symbolically this way,
but the frictional force is not a function of x alone,
but if you knew which path you're taking and which way are moving,
you can do that integral.
You want to do this in higher dimensions,
in higher dimensions.
What I found out was that if you want that,
the chance of Canada energy to be the work done than what you had to do was to
write this expression,
which was a shorthand for Fx Dx plus f y the y.
So you take a point and you go to the neighboring point.
That's the work done and this work done with cooktop so that it was a change in
Kennedy energy.
Then you'll say,
okay,
let me take a finite path.
Starting with some point od one and going through some point our tube.
Then I add up all the changes,
the lefthand side,
his kid to minus k one and the right 10 site.
Is this integral?
This is always true.
This will never be wrong.
Yes,
the restatement of Newton's law,
the problem will be can be right this integral here as a difference of two
numbers.
One depending on the starting 0.1 depending on the ending point.
Is this possible?
I have to say question mark.
If it's possible you're done because you're back to right in k one plus you want
to skate to bless you too,
but I tried to convince you that it's not always going to happen so let's
understand why it's not always going to happen.
It is not enough.
It is integral to say started r one and Gore to art too.
In fact,
if I just said find the integral of the work done by the force,
but in an odd one and r two you will have to tell me.
You'll have to ask me something.
You agree?
What will you ask?
In addition,
besides just saying started out when and ended our too.
What happens?
You will ask what path did you take and unless they specify the path,
you cannot do the integral because you don't know what contour you want to draw.
Therefore the answer in general depends on the path,
but this right hand side does not.
So if you pick the same two end points and you ready that path in this one right
answer,
it doesn't change but it's not hard to imagine.
The lefthand side would be different.
That foot in general,
this will not be true.
So even though there's a relation between work done and increase in Kennedy,
Kennedy,
you will not get a law of conservation of energy
unless this is true.
Then I said that is still a hope because we can in fact manufactured forces,
but with this is true.
The manufacturer of the force,
you pick any function,
you have x and y that you like.
Then define a new force who is x component is minus that did have it to of you
with respect to x and it was white component.
Just the minus,
a bit of it to you respect and why.
Then you got to go back and look at your notes and see that if you take f.
Dot.
D are now,
you're just adding the change in you and when you go from start to finish the
tour to change,
you will in fact be the change in you from start to finish and warm depending on
how you got there.
So you're basically what you're doing is in the x y plane,
you are defining a function.
You have x,
which is lake a height.
You define the force in a clever way so that f.
Dot.
The art is the change in the height as you march.
So you can start at any point on the mountain,
go to any of the point of the mountain.
If you're only keeping track of the change in height,
you're going to get the same answer no matter how you got from here to there.
So you start with the potential and work out a force and that force will then
obviously give an answer that's path independent and the potential associated
with the force is the function you began with.
In other words in this problem,
then k one plus you one will be kid two plus youtube where you as the same guy
you began with
so you can get a lot of conservation and energy in that case.
Then I told you without proof that this is the only way it can happen.
In other words,
we all agree that if you got a force from a potential by taking derivatives,
it does the job,
but I'm saying every force who is integral is independent of path.
We'll always have as his ancestor a function,
you and the x component of the force will be the extent of it to,
of the PR function and why it will be the way that that's not obvious,
but in other words it's clear,
it's sufficient,
but it's also necessary so every conservative force is the date of it to have
some potential in this fashion.
Finally I said,
if someone comes and gives you a force and says,
is it conservative or not?
Either you can think in your head and try to guess that function you have,
which this f is,
they did have active in this fashion.
If you succeed,
you know it's conservative.
If you fail,
maybe it's not conservative and maybe you are not clever enough in finding that
function.
So here is a recipe that works for all of this recipe is take that force,
take the d by d y of Fx and competitive the d by d,
x of F Y and if they're equal,
it's a conservative force.
That's the summary of last lecture.
How much detail you want noise entirely up to you.
Okay,
so now,
so I'm going to do a,
this is rescue doubled from last time,
so I'm going to
basically hide that.
If you want,
he can take a few moments writing it down,
but you understand the point.
No point is that are in fact if you think about his family,
miraculous that that our forces in nature so that the work done by them doesn't
depend on how you got from a to B.
Even more interesting is that all the fundamental forces that we know,
gravity,
electrostatics,
uh,
even the strong force,
weak force,
every fours that we know to the extent can be described by a force happens to be
conservative.
So it's not that we are hung up on some rather exceptional case.
Nature is kind enough that all the forces are conservative.
Now,
friction is a little tricky.
You might say,
well friction is not conservative,
but friction is not microscopic force a friction as it grows.
Average way to describe things at some real fundamental level.
Every forces,
in fact conservative.
Anyway,
gravity is conservative.
And then
uh Huh.
The electrostatic forces conservative also.
So if envy is steady conservative systems,
we're starting something fairly general.
So today I go to one of the famous conservative problems,
which is the gravitational interaction.
So the situation was as follows,
at Newton's time,
you know that corporate and Akers proposed that the way to think about our solar
system is to put the Sun at the center
now,
so hit us copper Nicos is picture.
Here's the sign here at various planets.
Yeah,
you have to agree.
That's very remarkable.
Okay.
First of all was remarkable because that was a period when you does not publish
or perish,
but publish and perish.
It's not a good thing to come out and say what you thought and you still did
that.
Even independent of the social risk.
How did anybody figure this out?
Because even today,
even when I know this is true,
I look around,
it doesn't look like this at all to my eyes.
So on a good day,
I flatter myself into thinking I could have maybe discovered this.
I discovered that there is no way I would've done this.
This is really amazing.
Go out and look,
because what you're saying is if you look at our solar system from far away,
it's going to look like this.
That's fine,
but what does our vantage point?
We're sitting on third rock and we're going around and we somehow think we are
at rest and everything is spinning around the opposite way and to deduce from
that chaos.
This is simple pick that is quite remarkable.
You got a lot of points just for saying this is what's happened.
That was a big,
it was properly called the corporate American revolution
after the corporate again revolution people that said take the data.
We get with this as the center and transcribed it with that as a center and plot
it.
So the person at Tyco,
Brian was a rich guy who had his own lab and he studied the solar system and
Kepler was an assistant who caddied on the word for 40 years,
40 years.
He studied this problem.
Then he published his answers.
I got to tell you,
all of you for going into science,
I would urge you not to publish every 40 years.
Okay,
you're tired,
you're going to get a job,
you're not going to get a phd,
not going to get a post doc.
You will be a 70 year old poster if you do this.
So the climate is very different now.
Even though we are a lot more money for science.
I don't think we have science.
You have money for science,
have such long vision.
The only example that comes to my mind is a work by Ray Davis who look for solar
neutrinos for about 30 years.
And fortunately the,
his reputation was so strong,
finding agencies kept him going.
It looked at neutrinos from the sun for 30 years to be really sure that that was
a problem.
And he confronted the theaters for the problem and the problem subsequently got
resolved.
But by in large,
people publish not a paper in 30 years,
but rather the goal is 30 papers a year is more what we want to do.
But you've got to realize that we're not much smarter than our ancestors.
And the fact that possibility that we have 30 excellent ideas a year is very
unlikely.
So I have to admire somebody like Kepler,
who after 40 years gave us something that is really solid gold because that's
what triggered that.
What set Newton on the right path.
So that are three laws of Kepler.
Okay.
So three loss in 40 years.
It's still better than congress had his,
what he had.
The first law is all planets going around the sun on an elliptical orbit with
the sun as the focus.
I'm not going to write all the words and take me forever to write it.
I'm just saying elliptical orbit.
And you guys can get the precise texts from any source you like.
But I have to remind you what elliptical orbit means,
right?
So everyone has to know what an ellipsis.
So you draw a circle,
you'd take a thumbtack,
you stick it into your table,
you take a string form a loop like that.
Put a pencil here and keep the pencil tight and walk around keeping the
distance.
You get a circle
for an ellipse,
you take two thumbtacks and you take a string like this,
keeping that length plus that length constant and you move keeping the string
tight and the shape you produces the ellipse.
And these are the two focal points,
f one and f two
ellipsis,
an egg shaped circle.
And if you want to get the circle back from the Ls,
you've just moved the two focal points to a single point and you will get the
circle.
That's a circle as only a single number are the radius characterizing it.
The LFC has what's called a major access and a minor axis and major access to a
and a,
it's called the semi major axis,
which is that this.
So do you know how you can get an ellipse way?
The Greeks were studying ellipsis where they come from.
Yes.
You have one that's in your reflection and you use the plane as the section sort
of cut through Easter called cones at different angles.
The uh,
outlined,
uh,
east,
cones.
These kind of sections will be elliptical,
that'd be ellipsis circles.
There'll be various famous John Metric figures.
I think for our purposes,
even if it took a single cone and you cut it or some angle,
that would be an Ellis,
that's where the Greeks were studying this.
But you need a second phone call and for other things.
But for now,
if you slice a cone parallel to the base,
you'll get a circle at an angle,
you'll get yellows.
So that's the first statement.
The second statement is the following.
If you
pick one planet and it's there today,
right?
You wait a week there and you wait another week,
it's there.
You join these two lines and you call that the area swept out by the planet in
the first week.
Then in the second week areas area,
notice that certain area intercepted by the two radio vectors and the arc along
which you move.
And Kepler said the rate at which the area is web cloud,
let's dad to be a shorthand for how much areas covered in a certain time.
So you take the area swept or divide the Delta t and he said that's a constant.
And the third result
is that,
let me see the square of the time it takes the planet to go around the sun
divided by the cube of the arbiters size.
It's the same for all planets.
Yeah,
that's it.
These are the three laws of Kepler.
Yup.
But you don't need calculus to do what I just said.
Calculus says,
take the limit.
Delta t goes to zero.
You've dealt at ps one day or one month.
It really doesn't matter.
Take a planet like Pluto.
I'm going to keep calling it a planet because I'm,
I'm attached to Pluto more than to the some of the newer guys,
you wait one month,
you see how much areas covered than wait another month.
You would still find it's true.
In fact,
it happens to be true even if it's not infinitesimally you can read even finite
periods,
but this is the limit.
Yup.
That lots of deviations
because
no,
Oh,
okay.
That are lots of connections to Kepler's laws.
First of all,
Kepler's law.
If we really observed with very carefully,
none of these things will actually work.
First of all,
planets are not moving just around the sun.
They have the pool of other planets.
Secondly,
a Newtonian law of gravitation,
which we'll study today,
has gotten modification from Einstein's theory,
which also modify the orbits.
In fact,
the truth is the planners don't follow close orbits at all.
But at the ellipse,
instead of starting out this way and staying this way forever slowly rotates.
And that's called the precision of the orbit.
And the one of the biggest mysteries was mercury had a precision.
In other words,
the orbit was not closing,
but,
uh,
like a Rosetta stone.
It is doing this,
not at this rate,
but very,
very slowly.
The majority of that precision has fully understood by the ethics that I
mentioned to you,
namely the fact that other forces on it,
Jupiter particularly,
is very massive planet.
You cannot ignore this effect,
but still there is a tiny part that was missing,
which is 43rd degree of an arc percent.
Very,
very,
very small deviation left unexplained.
And the general theory of relativity filled in that gap.
So the answer is every lie I told you long back,
we'll receive corrections,
but they usually very small.
Anyway,
this was the data that was given to Newton.
So Newton as you know,
uh,
was sent home from college because that was a plague and he went and lived in
this old village and he was contemplating this issue because he had already by
this time invented the loss of motion.
And I think it also invented the basic ideas of calculus.
That is some debate about who got there first.
But there was no debate about what happened next.
So Newton said,
okay,
I'm going to understand planetary motion.
And so are you.
So you guys have been terribly disappointed that after all the work you put in,
you're still doing inclined planes and police and whatnot.
So today we're going to make a big leap because today you're going to understand
how planets move around the sun.
That's the mega problem,
right?
The little ams you put in the equation and not massive or pulley or a plane,
but massive Jupiter mass of the sun.
So you're doing something of cosmological proportions and you don't need to know
too much more to do that.
Okay?
You're almost there.
So I'm going to just tell you the one missing thing.
So what Newton had done is to realize that in order to understand motion of
bodies,
you have to associate a force with acceleration and rock with mass.
That was his contribution.
If you think it's forces that cost of velocity,
you look at a planet going around the sun and the velocity is pointing in
different directions at different times and you have to ask what can possibly be
propelling the planet in this loop?
You don't get any definite advancer.
On the other hand,
if you calculate the acceleration of the planet,
take the simple case where the planners going on a circle,
the acceleration at every instant points,
stewards the sun,
okay?
That's how,
that's where it's important.
Understand what forces are doing.
Forces are causing acceleration.
So Newton had already showed us and we have done many problems and a body
accelerates.
That's the reason for it.
Well,
all bodies are accelerating towards the sun.
It was fairly clear what the reason is.
The reason is the sun,
and you then postulate a force that's exerted by the sun on the planet that
bends it into a circle.
And your job is to find out that force.
What's the nature of the force?
So it is again here that Newton decided
that the force that
bends the planets around the sun is the same as the force that bends the moon
around the earth.
It was known by then.
The moon is also going around the earth.
So let's look at that problem.
So here's the earth
and here's the morning and is going on two years
now the moon is accelerating towards the earth and that's something we have
learned in this course.
Then he had us,
the famous apple also accelerating towards the earth
and Newton decided that the cost behind both the forces is a new force,
the force of gravity,
the same thing that pulls the apple as what pulls the mall.
So we have to now ask what is the nature of that force?
Okay,
you're going to write a formula for the forest first.
Let me look at the magnitude.
The direction is very clear.
It is directed towards the center of the Earth,
so I won't write that down.
Later on,
I will write you a formula with vectors.
Symbols in it so the vector will point to at the center of the earth.
But let's look at the magnitude.
If you take an apple here of mass m and you call big game,
the mass of the earth near the earth,
we all know the acceleration of a body is constant.
Therefore it can happen only if the force depends on the mass of the APP.
This force is going to depend on various things.
I'm going to write the formula,
but one thing,
it depends on,
it's got to be proportional.
Massive yaffle.
That's because then if you divide by n to get a,
the mass drops out and you understand the fact that everything near the earth
falls at the same rate.
The only way that can happen is if the forest depends on the mass of the apple.
You agreed that that m belongs there.
Okay.
If it doesn't belong there,
if you have something that depends on m square for or does it depend on Mrr,
you have a problem.
If the forest doesn't depend on the massive doll,
suppose the force on everybody near there.
It was a constant force than we need.
Divide by mass.
You find that heavier objects that have a smaller acceleration,
but that's not what you find.
So that's perfect.
And precise cancellation on the mass of the object,
all things fall at the same rate.
So I know I need this am here.
What else do I need?
You notice that from the third law of Newton,
if there's a force on the apple,
the apple must exert a similar force on the earth.
So if you take an example in which here's the earth and here's the apple,
that's a little am sitting there.
But imagine the Apple's getting bigger and bigger because the formula is not
going to change.
Make it bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger until it looks like the apple is
that big in the earth is that big?
Then you will have to agree that,
uh,
from that point of view,
you should also have the mass of the earth here playing a symmetric role.
So these two masses have to be there.
But then what else should I have there?
I mean,
what are the other variables in the problem?
Yes,
the distance between them and I don't know what the distance dependence is,
I'm going to say that some function of the distance between them
so we don't know what the distance is.
All right,
so let's find the acceleration of the apple that happens to be the mass of the
earth.
This function with our calculated to be the radius of the earth.
Then you go to the moon and you ask what's the acceleration of the moon?
Okay.
It's the mass of the Earth Times the same function of the radius of the lunar
orbit.
Does anybody know how far the Munez?
Any guests?
You know,
how far this make a wild guess.
Okay.
Million Miles.
Not Bad.
Uh,
but not quite there.
Any other guests?
Yes.
Pretty close.
At 238,000 miles.
So that squatter of a million miles,
so million's not bad.
Okay.
If you make an estimate is off by a factor of Pi in physics it's fine.
But if you say 10 miles or something,
then we should have a talk.
We should have a very long talk after class.
Okay,
so that's correct.
So this guy is 240,000 miles just to be simple.
The radius of the earth.
How bout that?
Yes.
Uh,
how bout
in good old fashion?
Miles?
Three times
10 to the six would be a million miles.
Okay.
Anybody have a quick answer to how many miles?
What's the circumference of the earth?
Okay.
Then you can do the math and find out the radius.
Two is like six radius is 4,000 miles.
This is 4,000 miles.
This is 24 to 40,000 miles.
Look,
I know that we should work with meters and kilometers,
but like the rest of you guys,
once they get on the freeway,
I'm watching how many miles per hour and driving,
not meters per second because I have no idea what?
55 miles per hours.
So we do use a lot of British units.
If you go by installation at home depot,
it's in BTUs per slug,
per pound for something,
right?
So we still do that.
So in some sense you wonder why you had the war of independence if you're still
using those units.
Because that's about the worst part of the whole system,
but we still use it.
So my brain is split.
When I do physics,
uh,
I use the metric system.
When I go to home depot,
I use the home depot units.
All right,
so here is the two accelerations.
Let's take the ratio of those two numbers.
Now,
Apple's acceleration,
all of you guys know,
right?
It's the one thing we know from day one,
9.8 meters per second square acceleration of the moon.
How am I going to find that?
So I need an idea on how to find the acceleration of the moon.
Anybody from this corner of the room on the top,
how do I find acceleration of the moon towards the yard?
What do we do?
I have to know.
Yes,
very good.
That's what all I wanted from you.
We'll fill in the blanks,
but it's v squared over R and artists this quarter of a million miles and v is
the orbital velocity.
But you may not know the orbital velocity of the moon,
but you know,
it goes around every 28 days or something,
right?
So philosophy is to pay out over 28 days.
Put it in the second you get some acceleration.
Yes.
Right,
exactly.
In fact,
if not a circle,
it's much more complicated.
So in this calculation will assume everything is a circle.
It turns out to be not so bad even for planets.
So if you do the v squared over R,
you put the numbers in and you find the acceleration of the apple is 3,600 times
more than the acceleration of the moon.
On the other hand,
you find the apple and the moon radio [inaudible] our factor of 60 apart.
The moon is 60 times as far from the center of the Earth as the apple.
And you look at 60 you look like 3,600 right?
You don't have to be a Newton to figure out what's going on.
The News at four write down this great formula.
Do you understand now that that r squared or have you get the r square again?
It's pretty remarkable because it's gotta be an r to the power 2.01 and you
would certainly not,
no you're wrong because these numbers are not known that well.
Newton just said,
look,
let me take the nearest integer power.
It looks like close enough to one over r squared happens to be one over r
squared is a fantastically good approximation to the law of gravity.
So we would also quite fortunate there the laws of gravity didn't have to be
that simple.
Okay,
so now are we done are,
should I do something else to this?
Pardon me?
Uh,
this is the force I need.
What else?
Now
I get one.
If you have to put your hand up and take a stance.
Yes,
you have to say something constant.
A constant,
right.
Why do you need the cons?
Um,
because if you just work five that we had on the board and we probably wouldn't
get exactly that answer.
Very good.
Yes.
Look at the units.
Okay.
Units don't match.
Right?
So if some kid call ice,
it comes to you and says,
I got this new law of gravitation.
I would say go back and fix your units.
Units don't match,
but not only that,
I think some of you had another objection that if you took a the mass of the
earth and mass of the moon,
I'm the apple and divided by the radius,
you will get a number that won't agree with the force of gravity near the earth
as we know it.
So the point is when the function is proportionate,
all these things that is always a proportionality constant and the constants,
one of the purposes of the constant is to make the dimensions commode,
right?
Others to make the values come out right.
Cause I got to make sure that veneer play it to an apple near the earth.
I put the mass of the apple,
let's say divide by the apple,
this whole thing,
what should it be equal to?
It's got to be 9.8 do you understand that the acceleration of the apple near the
earth has to be 9.8 if I put the radius of the earth you,
it's better be 9.8
so you pick a number of GE,
which is some number six times 10 to the minus 11 and the unit four g are some
number times,
uh,
Newton meters square or kilogram square.
That'll make the units come out right?
So that's called the big g.
That's the gravity.
This is alive.
Universal is a universal gravitational constant am almost ready to write down.
Now the great Newtonian law,
Great Newtonian law says F is equal to m m over r squared.
But these are two objects,
have mass,
little lemon,
big began at a distance are from each other,
but it's not yet the vector.
This is just a number.
So I want to say that if this is one masters,
here's the other mass.
I want to say this one feels safe force towards the center.
So let me take the earth to be the center here.
I want the force on the moon.
I want to vector pointing towards the center,
so I know one vector that's pointing away from the second vector which is the
position vector R,
but if I divide that by the length of the position vector are,
I think all of you know in a factors to understand this vector has linked one
and points away from the center,
but I wanted to be pointing towards the center and that is then
the force of gravity on the moon or on the APP or any object.
If I'm thinking of one fixed object like the earth,
this the force on the apple.
If you think of two objects of comparable size,
you will have to say the forest on one do or the other.
Okay,
but new right,
the formula.
Then you got to make sure that the force one one is pointing to the other one
and force on that guy is pointing towards the sky,
so that is no universal symbol for all those things.
I will write it in the simple case where we imagine that the center,
some massive object like the sun and something tiny going around it.
Then the center of coordinators has chosen to be at the center of the massive
object.
This is the forest on the little guy.
This is the law of gravity.
It's called the law of universal gravitation because it's really a universal,
you've got to realize that was a tremendous leap of faith to believe that the
laws that are operative near the surface of the earth also apply to the moon and
also apply to the planets.
This was the year of 6,100 and something,
you know,
that was witchcraft and people at all kinds of superstitions.
People are not even thinking in scientific ways that a lot of illusions about
what they haven't sort of made off to believe that made up of similar stuff and
controlled by the same laws.
That's very obvious now,
but it was very far from obvious in those days.
It's a tremendous leap of faith and luckily for us that leap of faith is
justified because the laws of gravitation,
in fact the laws of physics that we did use near the earth seem to work all over
the entire universe.
If you've seen pictures and Nova where we are in the scheme of things,
we are in a very tiny part,
the universe sampling a tiny volume over the tiny period of time.
But we apply those equations to the far end of the galaxy,
the far end of the universe and going all the way back to big bank
and be predict the future fate of the universe.
So we assumed that the laws that we discover here now or ballot everywhere and
at all times so far that seems to be true and that's the big break for us.
But for that you really couldn't do anything if the last year discovered today
are not valid tomorrow you cannot make any predictions.
So it's another unwritten benefit we got.
I mean an unspoken offers a great benefit that the loss you find are universal,
but somebody had to stay,
you know,
stick his neck out and say it.
This is one of the first occasions.
So now you're going to apply this law to understand what Kepler did.
Okay,
so what do you have to do to do what capital did?
So we are going to consider the motion of a planet.
I don't the sun.
Let's put the sign here.
That's what the planet here,
the planets at their location are.
You go back as usual to the only equation in town.
Hey,
f equals m a no.
F I told you has to be deduced every time,
but painstaking experimental data without that ethical time is useless.
If you don't know what's on the lefthand side independently,
let me repeat again.
You don't say the force on the body is Amy forcing the body's dude with spraying
due to gravity.
Do the charges,
whatever.
You have to do some work to find this.
Then you put it into that equation,
but let's put in here the right hand side of Newton's life can be written once
and for all.
The two are.
Now I'm writing d to auto with Dt square because I'm living in two dimensions.
Now on the left hand side I have this new result,
g m m four what?
R squared times.
I'm going to use a symbol of our hat,
which is very common or anything with a hat on it.
It's the set of unit length pointing in the direction of the regular vector are.
So if you want,
if art is the position vector of an object whose length is our our head as a
little guy
who's length this one and with the points in the radial direction,
so this is your equation.
Then a problem in calculus to solve the equation and everything Kepler said
should come out of that.
You should find planets like the moving elliptical orbits.
You should find the area swept out as a constant.
Did you find a square of the time period is proportional?
The Cuba,
the Arbid sites?
No.
If I give this to us and the homework problem in the class,
I dare say it will be very difficult for most of you.
I don't know what kind of background do you had?
You have done some calculus but it's not easy,
but remarkably Newton also solve this problem.
Even now when I teach in physics 400 and something for advanced mechanics,
it takes a while to know how to solve this equation is one thing to write it
down.
Other thing to actually solve it and get the hell out of it.
So Newton did that too,
so it's really amazing.
That's why he's such a giant.
You have to step back to that period in time and ask what did the one person
accomplish over the period of board five years?
So that was how physics has always done.
Somebody looks at the data,
sometimes summarizes the data in the form of certain phenomenal logical facts
like the laws of Kepler that somebody else has to like a theoretical person has
to figure out what does the underlying rules of this game right to the
mathematical form and solve the mathematics and Betty fight.
Just imagine that you wrote this equation but you couldn't solve it.
What you'd be saying would actually be correct you.
In fact,
I found the correct law of gravity,
but you can never be sure it's right because you cannot find the consequences of
your equation.
That is not unheard of.
That's happening in physics today,
for example.
That is the theory of quarks.
The quarks are attracted each other by a certain mechanism.
We know,
we know the underlying force law and from that we are supposed to find the
understand the existence of all particles like protons and neutrons and so on.
We do not yet have a way to show without any doubt that the underlying equations
imply the phenomenon that we see when we applied it to the problem of quirks,
but putting it on a big computer,
we have fairly certain that's correct.
That would be like solving Newton's laws on a computer,
but what Newton did was done solid on the computer,
but solve it analytically.
So quite often in the past,
whenever the theory is accepted,
it's because the consequences can be worked out and compared experiment.
But you could be in a position where you have the right theory in the right
equations,
but you cannot solve them anyway.
This one happens to be solvable.
If I change the forest lot to one over art at the 2.1 then it's a different
story.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so we want to solve it,
but we cannot do the ellipse.
Okay.
It's too hard.
So we're going to do the circle.
We're going to take arbit to be circular and we're going to apply this force a
lot of that and see what we can get.
So let's do that.
We can ask ourselves,
can have planets have a circular orbit
of radius?
Are
we go back to f equals m a and now you guys had expert on the right hand side.
Now we are assuming the planet moves around the circle.
That constant velocity at constant speed we want to ask can set an orbit exist.
You're always allowed in any equation to make an assumption and plug it in and
see if it works.
If the left hand side and the right hand side,
Matt,
you win.
Nobody will ask you any more questions.
So we are asking for a modest goal.
Can I find an orbit of a planet going around at constant speed around the sun on
a circle?
Let the constant speed BV than MMA.
Everyone seems to know is MV squared over R
and is pointing towards the center.
That's we should be equal at the force pointing towards the center.
And Newton has told us what the forces at g m m over r square.
Everybody understand.
Now the left hand side is the effect.
The right hand side is a cause.
If for spending a rock spinning it on a circle,
that also is an acceleration toward the center,
but the string is providing the force and you can work out the force of the
spring of the string here.
It's the unseen force of gravity from the sun reaching or the planet and pulling
it in.
Newton tells you the formula,
the dues from Ted Estriol and lunar observations now applied to planets.
Okay,
so this is something that should make you very happy because this is a very
simple application of ethicals handmade,
but you're describing planetary motion.
So these are all masters of big guys,
the earth and the sun.
So let's cancel the R and I get canceled.
The mass.
That's very interesting.
So that says v square are equal to GM.
Yeah,
it says,
yes,
you can have a circular orbit.
Okay.
Any radius you like provided you move at the speed,
satisfying this equation.
And as long as you satisfy the equation,
I don't care if the thing that's spinning is a satellite or a potato because the
mass of the object drops out.
So the condition for orbit is independent of the object orbiting again,
due to this cancellation of the mass in both sides.
All right,
so this is all we can get out of Newton's laws.
And let's go back to the Kepler.
Is the orbit possible?
Well,
if you say an ellipse circle as a special case of the LMC of shown circular
orbits are possible,
how about equal areas in equal time?
It's obviously true in this problem because it's going at constant speed.
If it goes that far in one week and go that far in one week and everyone can
tell the area swept all this constantly.
So the only thing left to knock off as a third assumption,
the third observation of Kepler involving the time period.
So I do the simplest thing.
I said the velocity of this planet is to buy our divided by the time period.
I put that in here and I get four Pi r squared,
r cubed over t square is GM or I find art cubed over t square is equal to
eliminate a t squared over r Q because that's how capital wrote it.
This says t square divided by r cubed is equal to four Pi square over GM.
So that's another result you got right away.
That's the third result that the time period ended.
The orbital radius here is what the Newton do.
That's went further than Kepler.
Can you tell me what he did that's really beyond heavy,
just verified Kepler's laws.
I'd be gone a little beyond that.
Yup,
exactly right.
Let me repeat what he said.
Kepler said t square a cube.
This the same thing,
but he didn't tell you what the same thing is.
What does the constant,
well now we know that constant to be for dawn to Oliver's Pi on two Oliver's m
massive earth and g and mass of the sun and g is the universal constant of
gravitation.
So you calculate the value.
Similar thing happen in atomic physics.
Uh,
a high school teacher called bomber was studying the spectral lines coming out
of an atom and they were coming out at different frequencies and he said all the
frequencies you'll ever see coming out of an atom local,
like some number times one over one into their square times,
one over different integer square.
He didn't know what the number was,
but it's some constant,
I mean,
he knew the number,
but he didn't know he knew the number,
but he didn't know where it came from.
And Board had this final theory of the atom.
It had the exactly this form,
but this,
we're just not simply a constant and you put ended involved pie and the electric
charge and the Planck's constant everything.
So bomber did four bore what Capitol did for Newton.
It's the condense a complicated data into some simple forms so that the
theorists can have a go at it.
Then once you got the right answer,
it's really beautiful how everything fits.
So we know this is right.
Okay.
This is called a theory.
By the time physicists will call something a theory there,
pull it to a lot of tests.
Okay.
It's not to be casually used and you have the right theory.
You can make a lot of predictions.
You can have a theory.
The planners go around the sun because some angels are flapping their wings and
I say,
where are the angels?
You say,
well,
part of the theory is you don't see them.
So very good.
What's your next prediction?
Tell me when the next eclipses.
Tell me if the meat you're headed for earth is going to hit or miss.
Is this comment going to reappear or is it a one sharp thing?
If you cannot answer any of that,
you don't have a theory.
You have an interpretation of past data that coincides with past data that's
worth nothing.
Okay,
so here's an example of how to do it right.
so
this thing has got enormous power.
It tells you if you find another planet,
you find a new planet tomorrow.
If you know how far it is,
I'll tell you what a year is in the planet.
I'll tell you how long the planet takes to go around the sun because t squared
over r cubed is known to me.
So if that planted this at a certain distance,
I can tell you the time period or if I see it going around the sun and I know
it's going to complete the evolution in 240 years,
I can tell you how far it is.
So that's another power of the,
okay,
so now
you can do variety of problems using this formula.
They're all plugged in check,
but I'll just mentioned one and most problems are like that.
Everything's going to be plugging into this formula.
But one interesting example is the following.
So here's the earth.
I'm here and I wanted to watch a tennis game being played there.
I have radio waves,
but you know,
radio waves cannot go through the earth.
They can only travel in straight lines.
And the answer to that,
but I think all of you know,
is to have a bunch of satellites,
uh,
three of them in particular forming a nice triangle.
And if you can talk to this satellite from where you are,
that satellite with the help of the other two can always at any other points you
want this bit bouncing off.
Okay.
You bounce off this,
you can go there and you can hit this guy.
So if you have three satellites,
they can help you connect any point on the earth to any other point by
reflecting off the satellites.
But the important thing is the satellites better be where do you think they are?
They're constantly moving it on.
It doesn't work.
So what do you really want is what's called geosynchronous satellites.
The satellites.
Remember if I look at the earth from the top,
it is spinning.
This is the North Pole and you're spinning.
Therefore these satellites should be rotating around the earth once every 24
hours.
Then if they're on top of your head today,
there'll be on your top of your head all the time,
right?
So the time period of the satellite as 24 hours,
then the only question is at what altitude should I launch them?
You go to this formula,
put in 24 hours,
right it in seconds,
you will get the radius.
And once you got the radius,
this equation will tell you at what velocity they should be put into orbit.
That's it.
That's how you put the geosynchronous satellite.
That's a simple example of applying the formula.
I won't give other examples,
but they're always going to be finding t from mater.
Finding our from tea.
Sometimes you'll know are sometimes you will not take
any question about this.
Okay,
now I'm going to come to the question of energy.
I never do.
You have a new forest.
You can talk about the law of conservation of energy.
So I want to ask myself,
what's the potential energy I can associate with the gravitational force?
I can ask myself,
is it even a conservative force?
So let's take the problem in two stages.
First of all,
if you're near the earth,
everything falls down near the earth.
If that height is y,
then the force of gravity is minus m g with Jay,
but Jay's unit veteran,
that direction,
the potential energy is then AMG.
Why?
And everybody can check that.
You could take the minus the white Ditto to this.
You get the force.
That's the potential energy and therefore when a body's falling in near the
surface of the earth,
we may assert that one half Mv Square plus m g,
let me call it height instead of y.
Let me call this coordinate eight instead of white.
I don't think it matters too much.
That is the total energy.
That is a constant.
We applied at the other day,
the roller coaster's going up and down,
speeding up and slowing down.
It's just that this number will not change.
That's the roller coaster changes.
The height,
the speed must change.
Keeping this number constantly.
What do you know this formula is an approximation near the earth.
Be One.
Apply it globally
before going the global problem.
Let me remember one more thing.
That g is equal to g m over r e square
because when you apply Newton's law to the surface of the earth,
you better get this number g when you apply it to something near the year.
By the way,
Newton took a long time to publish this law of gravitation.
Does anybody know why he was holding back for a long time?
Have you heard of anything?
Yes.
Um,
was uh,
in the controversy over the discovery of the calculus with lightness and then I
convinced them later on,
uh,
Edmund Halley may have convinced him to publish,
but it was something else that is bothering Newton.
Yes.
Here's a free,
he is afraid of criticism.
Uh,
maybe,
but that was not why he held back.
Yes,
very much.
Pardon me.
I'll sit down.
Good,
great.
Awesome.
No,
but look,
many applied it by the way he applied it to everything.
So let's steal motion.
The behavior of tides.
Everything seemed to work.
That is one further assumption that you make.
When I wrote the one over our East Square,
I said the distance of the APP and from the earth is that,
and maybe it should be just the two meters from which they release it.
Somehow he knew you have to measure the distance from the center of the earth.
So it is not clear for the purposes of gravitation.
Another words.
Originally Newton had a law of gravitation between two point objects,
namely the point like the distance between them and ambiguously the distance
between the points and he got this law,
but in the end he wants to apply it to the earth and the apple,
they are close enough for you.
You cannot pretend the earth look like a point from where I am.
It looked like a big fat thing.
You cannot say it's point like,
so what you really should do is buy there to the tiny pieces each of at this
point like pine,
the force on each from each chunk of the earth using this law and added up.
And if you're lucky,
it will look as if all the pull is coming from one point at the center carrying
the Untied Massive Year.
So what branch of mathematics do you have to use to get that result?
Yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
what branch of mathematics?
What can calculus calculators had it been invented?
No.
So he had to then invent integral calculus also.
So you know if he felt that no one around him was doing any work,
probably justified because they just dumped the whole thing on his kid and said,
why don't you do integrity?
That's why it took him a long time to verify using integros that the fear
behaves like a point particle at the center.
He knew it works because all these numbers couldn't be on.
The coincidences are not coincidence.
He believed it worked,
but he had not found a way to show it.
That's what held back publication.
Okay.
That's another rare behavior.
Anyway,
I come to this problem and I say I want a plate not near the earth,
but arbitrarily far
near the earth,
the forces minus mg,
but far from the earth,
many,
many miles away.
The forest is really what we wrote here is minus G M M over R squared times r
unit vector in the radial direction.
First thing you can check is that this is actually a conservative force.
I'm going to give this to you.
I don't have time to do that.
In other words,
write this capital r hat if you like.
What's an r divided by one more out in the bottom you don't care.
And that can be written as minus g m m
times.
I times x over r cubed plus j times wire would argued,
right.
I just wrote the vector art in terms of x and y.
So the x component of this force is x over our cube.
The why is why you would argue artists just square root of x squared plus Weist
with,
yeah,
so maybe you can tell me what should I do to check to this?
A conservative force
[inaudible]
yes,
I will repeat what he said.
That's the correct answer.
I mistake the x component of this.
Take the white parts a little bit to the white component of this digging x
partial derivatives.
You guys should do that when you take the date of it to have something like one
over r cubed,
you should first take the art data to of r cubed and then take the x derivative
of art.
The way using the chain rule of calculus,
you will find the to agree so we know it's conservative.
That's the power of the rezone.
All you have to do is guess potential could have led to this force.
So I say,
okay,
let's put the sun here.
Let me move along the x axis.
The force along the x axis look like mine is g,
m m o what?
X squared,
because x is just are you feel moving in this direction the other direction?
That's our,
but let me just move along the aesthetics.
I asked myself what function has the property that minus the did it,
but to have that with respect to x,
looks like this.
That's,
that's a Mickey mouse.
Countless problem.
It just minus one over the X.
Okay,
they do.
I do.
A minus one over x is minus one over x squared.
That photo exes are in general,
the you that you want for gravitation,
it looks like this.
So gravitational potential energy for problems arbitrarily far from the center
of this mass.
Not near just the surface of the earth,
but wherever you go in any gravitation problem,
this is you.
Okay?
You can check that if you took this you,
that's what I'm telling you guys to do.
If you really care that I missed something
that'd be positive.
No.
Let's see if you took the art a little bit about this one or what artists are
the minus one bit of battle,
Make It plus one over r square.
What do you really supposed to take?
Minus they did have it,
two of you and that it be the right thing.
So this is the potential energy.
This will be negative.
Okay,
so what I'm a claiming,
I'm claiming that if you've got the sun and you got some other planet moving
around it,
the fallen quantity will not change.
Which this one half MV squared minus G M M over R is a constant.
Yeah.
No,
take an object moving near the earth.
I gave you a different rule.
I said near the earth.
Why did I say the rule was the constant is one half Mv Square let's MGH
can,
are they going to do looks right?
Potential energy looks really wrong.
That seems to be two definitions of potential energy.
They don't even agree in sign.
So what's going on?
What's the way out of this
problem?
I mean,
do you have any idea?
That's good.
Can you buy it?
Uh,
big g.
You mean our little g little g by the problem.
Oh,
that's not a bad idea.
Suppose I do that.
That's a very good idea.
So let me write that.
A G M m over r e squared.
Time's sakes.
That's a good plan.
But do you notice this cannot possibly equal that because that's negative,
right?
This is positive.
Any way to reconcile this?
Yes.
Well,
differences because the first one is for different values of force,
while the second one is assuming
constantly.
I agree,
but no one doesn't.
The Cotsen the certainly it's true that near the earth we treat it as a
constant.
But if at the formula balance for every distance and I specialize it to the
problem near the earth,
it's gotta agree with the problem near the earth.
Right?
The bigger formula should embrace our enclosed a smaller formula
equal.
Yeah,
I will do that.
In other words,
I grant you,
I'm willing to put Ari he here.
Right?
But that is no way this expression and this can match because they're not even
have the right side.
You don't even have to think more than that.
They cannot be great as they are.
Yes.
Maybe kind of explain agent
no.
Eight is the number of meters above the ground.
You put the number in.
Look,
most of your escape routes don't work because you're trying to get a positive
number two equal a negative number.
Yes.
Thank you.
I didn't know I was going home for lunch because I was not going to proceed
because I got the right answer.
The right answer is when you define a potential,
there is a freedom to add a constant to the definition of the potential.
You can look at every theater.
I'm everything I derived including the stuff I hidden under the board.
You want minus youtube is what enters everywhere.
The change in Kennedy,
Kennedy is you want minus youtube.
Therefore,
one has a freedom in defining the potential to add a constant and what has
happened is the person working with this potential and the person working with
this potential have not taken the same reference point.
This person working near the Earth said,
let me choose for convenience.
The potential at height equals zero to be zero because that's a natural point
for me.
What about this person here?
Yup.
He's saying potential is zero at infinity because when you're doing celestial
mechanics here,
there's one object,
other objects of various distances.
Infinities rather interesting point.
You go infinitely far from it,
no potential energy.
So there are two of them differ by a constant.
That's the reason why and the constant can easily overturn a quantity that is
negative and bring it up to positive values.
So except for that constant,
once they add a certain constant,
everything should work out.
So I will show you that it does.
Okay.
Then everything will be fine.
Maybe there are two ways to do it.
I'm in two minds on how to show the two ways.
I'll try one method.
Let's take the answer that's valid for all distances,
right?
That's the seller still formula.
Forget all the constants it looks like minus one over r.
You agree some blahblahblah constant divided by R,
so it's a graph that looks like this.
It blows up to minus infinity,
even Argos to zero and it goes to zero when our ghost infinity.
This is the formula for you,
for the person who saves you a zero and infinity.
Now let's look at the formula in the neighborhood off the surface of the earth.
Here is where we are most of the time.
Okay,
so if I shift my zero to here,
okay,
then by design I made you to be a zero on the surface of the earth that let me
also measure the new coordinate this way called h,
which is the radial distance away from the Ari.
This is Ari,
this odd d plus h.
Then I blow up this box.
What do you find?
I blow up the box with my newly shifted origin,
hit his age.
And here is the potential energy looking like a straight line.
And if you're lucky,
the slope of this rate line should be what?
What should it be?
The slope.
So we can reconcile everything.
If a function is a straight line,
it has a certain slope.
What's the wave coordinator?
Slope Times the x coordinate.
Yes.
Not g yes mg.
If it's AMG you for,
that's a slow MD.
At times h would be the function you're drawing.
Right?
So that's all I have to show you.
And I will show that that's what happens then we're set.
So let's take the master formula for the potential energy.
Right at g m m this applied to a distance
near the earth.
It's our plus h.
That's what we're trying to do right now.
So he must side that expression as mine.
His g m m over R,
yeah.
Times one plus h over our
that it just in the writing of this,
and you can write that.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
apologize.
Do you know what's wrong with what I wrote?
This is not our plus h.
What should I be really putting here?
Radius of the earth,
so I don't know how you're going to connect it in your notes,
but this really should be radius of the earth everywhere.
Here I want to be at a height eight about the radius of the year,
so I put that here.
Then I write this as minus G M and a over the radius of the earth times one plus
h over radius of the earth.
The power minus one.
I just bring the downstairs or the upstairs.
Then remember the wonderful Formula I told you,
you guys have to know this one plus extra,
the end.
It's approximately one plus annex.
If x is very small x's here,
the height over the radius of the earth,
which is obviously a tiny,
so I can approximate that and I get you equal to minus g m m over R e times one
plus g m m over r squared times eight.
Yeah.
This is the potential energy at the surface of the earth.
For a guy who thinks that zero to infinity,
this is the change in potential energy.
When you move a distance [inaudible].
Therefore,
if you calculate u of h minus,
you have zero,
you would cancel that term,
then you won't get the same answer as the person using this formula.
That's really important to understand how these two are saying the same thing
that is best understood.
In terms of the graph that I've drawn for you,
you shift your origin to one place and you also shift the uh,
zero potential to one place.
Now for the circular orbit,
what's the energy?
It's one half MV squared minus G M M over R,
but we know that one half Mv Square,
uh,
is v squared is equal to Mv Square.
It's a centrifugal force made the centripetal force that for you can write that
as g m m over r
minus G M M over r.
You find the answers then minus the potential energy over to,
or I'm sorry,
[inaudible] over to r minus the kinetic energy.
In other words,
if you combine these two terms,
you get minus g m m over to our,
okay?
So for a particle in a circular orbit,
the kinetic energy is exactly half the magnitude of the potential energy in the
total energy is negative.
Okay?
So I want to close with one very important results.
So whenever you see a celestial body,
here's the sun.
You see some sellers steel thing moving around,
you can compute the total energy.
The total energy is negative.
That object is bound to go on orbiting the sun.
It can never escaped infinity.
The total energy is positive.
It has a,
it can go to infinity and zero is the borderline case.
So why is it that the total energy is negative?
The body can never run off to infinity.
Can anyone think of a contradiction?
You would have a body of negative energy founders sell foot infinity?
Yes.
I mean,
look,
people have to get energy to go to infinity,
not infinity partner sell energy.
Zero.
What about candidate candidate?
Some positive number,
right?
But his initial energy was negative and you cannot change it.
So if you've got totally negative energy,
you cannot be found wandering around infinity because I'd infinity if you're
moving around,
you got positive candidate energy,
no potential energy,
and the energy was origin,
really negative.
You have no business being there.
So objects with negative energy will never escape.
So if you saw a comment you want them to,
if we'll come back again,
find the candidate plus potential.
If it's positive at one comeback,
but negative,
it's strapped.
That's the dividing line.
So if you're near the earth and he wanted to shoot something,
you can pick it in any direction you want.
Supposed to start shooting them up.
They go to different heights and one day you don't want it to come back.
You can ask yourself,
how fast do they fight a gun so the bullet never comes back?
Well,
you should fight it so that it can go to infinity.
When it goes to infinity,
you want it just manage to get that.
It's going to go to in front of these staggered and fall down while it's got no
candidate and it didn't finity.
He's got no potential energy.
Infinity.
Therefore,
the stored energy should be zero.
what you should do at the surface of the earth,
you're one half Mv Square,
minor,
g.
M,
m.
O.
What on Earth should be zero?
Are these two numbers should be equal or canceling the mass.
You'll find some formula,
which is v squared equal to g,
m,
two G,
So depending on the mass of the earth and gravitational constant radius of the
earth,
you'll get a velocity that's called the escape velocity.
When something is fired with escape velocity,
it will just about make it infinity.
You want to be really short,
it doesn't come back and give it a little extra speed,
little less it'll Arbor the they just won't go away.
All right,
so I want you to think about,
uh,
what you've learned because if you can now go and read articles,
for example,
you heard about dark matter,
I'll just say one sentence about dot.
Anybody heard about dark matter?
Okay.
Most of the universe seems to be made out of stuff we cannot see.
Okay?
You,
me,
we don't add up to anything very small percentage.
How do people know that is dark matter?
You cannot see it,
but do you know it's there?
How do you know it's there?
You know it's there because our galaxy or any galaxy has got matter.
You see and matter,
you don't see the draw an orbit around the galaxy going all the way around the
galaxy.
You can treat the entire mass of sitting at the center.
Then you can use your gravitational formula via square artists,
the enclosed mass.
If you go further out,
you should find you're not enclosing any more mass because the mass is all what
you see.
But what we find is as the orbit gets bigger than the galaxy be square are keeps
on increasing.
So the mass and close is increasing,
but you don't see that.
So we know that is mass,
which is not visible to visible observation,
but every galaxy galaxy seems to have this halo of dark matter that,
so we estimate the mass and it beats all the known mass.
But you can do that using just this calculation.